[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Melo from
Fandango and look who's just popped by
to have a chat about darkest hour hey
guys hello hello
director Joe Wright my favorite Winston
Churchill quote is a lie can get halfway
around the world while truth is still
putting on its shoes
this is such a brilliant film about
Winston Churchill right at the beginning
of World War two so one thing about
Winston Churchill is of course he was
such a great speaker and so many
brilliant speeches and quotes for you as
a filmmaker it was that an exciting
endeavor that you could really capture
these moments that could be cinematic on
screen not really no I was trying to
forget all of that an approach Winston
just as a character this guy on the page
who is in this situation which is one of
the most extraordinary situations in
history and to see how he copes and how
I identify with him so if I lionized him
too much then I wouldn't have been able
to do that in my deep deep research on
Wikipedia it appears that you might be
the 20th actor to play
in terms of TV and film
one of the things I think about playing
a Gary talks about this a bit playing a
historical figure that has been played
before you are influenced by those
performances in some way or another so
trying to watch original source material
and stuff and just clear that away as
best you can is is sort of part of the
part of the endeavor and I love
atonement and Pride and Prejudice so
then why would you say Joe was the right
director to take on this role Oh Joe has
allows his actors incredible space
incredible ownership he's a master of
atmospherics on set and I think Joe has
an absolutely wonderful profound even
take on a human that's a very rare
packet of gifts I know the right
director but
it's cuz we're in Camarillo
there we go
this an old job
thank you guys so much and
congratulations on the darkest hour it's
brilliant thanks thank you very much
thanks Don
[Music]